now remember I'm now in the mode of
solving simultaneously and we saw before
I've got three equations two variables
so I can choose which equations would
you like to do which ones feel easily
set up
I never actually had a media at the end
is that right oh of course it should
absolutely thank you for picking that up
It's All Greek to me okay once we fix
that up which equations would you like
to fit together
are good yep so you've noticed Mrs
aisles you've got a plus Lambda and a
minus Lambda Sean your approach would
have worked absolutely but it does seem
like it's kind of already easy to do so
let's go ahead and do one plus two
and what does that give us well I'm the
lambdas have canceled so I just get
negative one over there and then on the
right hand side just be careful with
your signs there right I'm adding the
right hand sides so if I'm doing this
right I think I've got negative three
plus two mu does that look right to you
okay I'll add um I'll add three to both
sides and I'll I'll place that I'll
switch the sides as well so if I'm doing
that right I think I'm getting two mu
equals two
so now I've got a value for Mu okay
excuse me now at this point about my
value for Mu I can substitute that into
any one or three equations which one
would you like
two okay two is fine
um let's go into two
so I've got here minus Lambda equals two
take away one so obviously there's one
on the right hand side and I can
multiply both sides by negative one so
that gives me this
let me pause
what we were trying to do again
we want to show that they intersect or
or alternatively that they may not right
now at this point I've got a excuse me
I've got a Lambda I've got a mu now to
find a point of intersection uh
excuse me if I wanted to find a point of
intersection the only thing I can do is
take Lambda and take mu and substitute
them back into one of the two equations
okay but in fact
um I don't have to find a point of in
section to know whether there is a point
of intersection can I just say that one
more time I don't have to find a point
of intersection to know whether there is
one or not
now I I can't find the point of
intersection if I will if I want and in
fact in a few minutes I'm going to do
that but uh to know that actually there
is a point of section the way that I'd
have to do this is I'd have to take this
value of mu this value of Lambda and I'd
have to do I'd have to substitute into
both R1 and R2 now that's doable but
it's a fair bit of work right and I'm
always seeking the fastest way to do
this okay there is another way to know
whether there's a point of intersection
or not without actually finding the
point of intersection can anyone suggest
any ideas for how we might do this
I'll admit it's a bit of a left turn
okay very good so this is third equation
here right now it's important because if
you have a look at this third equation
we really have not used it yet in
finding out Lambda and our mu now when
you've got two variables and two
equations provided that the two
equations don't represent parallel lines
You'll Always Find a point of
intersection that's kind of what we were
saying before do you remember that in
two Dimensions things will always meet
unless they're parallel okay so in other
words I'll always find a mu and I'll
always find a Lambda however that
doesn't mean it actually works with the
third equation because two equations
will always give you a solution for two
variables what I really need to do is I
actually need to take this mu and this
Lambda and and substitute them into the
third equation now
um if if I do have a point of
intersection the equation should work
right it should satisfy all three but if
there is no point of intersection then
what will happen is I'll try to put it
into the third equation and it will
break it won't work it satisfies two but
not the third one one okay now given
that at this moment in time I I don't
know
um here's what not to do don't just take
the third equation and put in Lambda and
mu and let them equal to each other
because you don't know we don't know
whether they're equal to one another or
not okay so what I'm going to do here's
the way I'll write it I would say I'm
going to sorry wrong thing I'm going to
now test
um equation three
because I don't actually know if I'm
going to satisfy it or not right so I'm
going to say first let's do the left
hand side so that's got a Lambda in it
right so I'm going to go 5 plus 2 and
here's my value for Lambda so what do I
get
three that's three and now I test the
right hand side so this should feel like
induction right you know when you test
the base case you don't actually know
whether the base case works even though
it would be a bit mean and silly for a
test rider to give you a statement that
isn't true for the base case because
then what's the point but in that case
you've got to look at the left you've
got to look at the right separately so
in this case my right hand side is 5
minus 2 mu which in this case is 1.
so this turns out 2b3 which we breathe a
sigh of relief as required so this means
that a satisfy equation three so finally
I can say
my value for Lambda my value for Mu they
work all the way X Y and Z they're all
equal so therefore R1 and R2 intersect
because I proved earlier that they're
orthogonal I can complete their
statement and I can say at right angles
does that make sense
[Applause]
now uh just for the sake of completeness
um I did mention right this is not the
only way to do it and when I was sort of
mentioning before we were kind of like
yeah what what is the other way right so
I just want to sort of prove to you that
this is faster what we just did here
it's faster and easier than going the
long way around which is to test that we
actually get a point on both lines
you've got to do it for both because you
don't know whether it actually is true
for both of them so what I would have to
do is I would have to substitute uh H
parameter Lambda and mu into their
respective lines so I would be
substituting Lambda into R1
so um hopefully I mean I've scrolled
past it but on your page you probably
have your equation there so it would
give you I think this is the position
vector and there's my Lambda and then
here comes the direction vector
right so when you simplify that out you
should get if you look at all of your
components across negative two and then
one positive and then that looks like a
three
and then you would have to substitute
um mu into R2 because not enough just to
find it for one line so again you've got
to go back it's got a different position
vector
and it has a different here comes mu it
has a different
um Direction Vector 3 negative one
negative two and again you've got to go
across so it looks like we do get the
negative two one three as required okay
so if you just want to do the counting
right effectively what we had to do here
was six um six equations as it were
right you do the X the Y and the Z for
R1 and then you do the X the Y and the Z
for R2 if you compare that to what we've
got up here even though it's more
writing it's actually much less
calculation and so therefore it's much
less error prone so I think that's a
preferable technique what we did here
substituting into the third equation
um but of course you know in another
context if they actually ask you to find
the point of intersection then sorry no
shortcuts you've actually gotta you've
got to do it this way okay
um
any questions does that make sense
yeah that's fine okay wonderful so those
are the two examples that I just wanted
to show you you'll encounter a couple of
other different kinds of questions when
you go through the rest of the exercise
but I thought those are those are quite
important and the presentation of
choices like uh which one of these do I
do first dot product or the point of
intersection
um which way do I work out whether
there's a point of intersection it's not
the same as actually finding the point
of intersection which is a very uh
nuanced difference and I find that when
I encountered this I didn't realize it
when I just did the question myself I
had to be shown